Lil pump Lil pump is here welcome man
good to see you buddy appreciate it man
thank you for having me for people who
don't know the first time I met you bro
was like uh it might have been like two
or three days before your 17th birthday
and you were at uh trapzilla's house in
Pacoima California no it wasn't even
Panorama City California
you and smoked purple just sleep in
there and it was it was just a random
random era of SoundCloud rap yeah that
was when I first came to LA and like I
want to say like that night or the night
after it was like your birthday party
you had your birthday party at like a
strip club yeah yeah good times man yeah
that was like uh Peak SoundCloud days
man literally what's been going on
though
traveling man yeah freaking working
working on a new album okay come out do
you feel like you're focused on music
again yeah I'm back focused on music
there was one point where I was just
like
it's too much right now yeah and you
know I just started [ __ ] off and then
I'm back on my [ __ ] again you're back on
your [ __ ] I was gonna say like
[ __ ] happens so fast for you and you
were like a literal kid yeah and I think
people forget that when they think a
little pump like because when I first
heard of you was um
the [ __ ] J Cole [ __ ] which was like
pretty early would you say yeah I was
like 16. yeah
um but it just happened so fast to a kid
like people I don't think people I think
when they talk about you and they
criticize you whether you know you've
given them reasons to criticize you or
not they forget that like bro you're a
[ __ ] kid and yeah I'm still 22.
you're only 22 years old but you also
kind of like grew up in front of our
eyes yeah no literally you know what I'm
saying like
um do you feel like
now that you've kind of like seen the
highs and lows of this rap [ __ ] like you
you feel like mentally you're in a good
good space yeah I'm in a way better
space not understand how like [ __ ] goes
and you know yeah I was young I was just
moving fast not thinking about nothing
right
now that I'm older I I see everything
now I was only 16 17 you know I was
crazy man no it's crazy yeah like you
said like I grew up fast it's like let's
say when
this year when I turned 22 people were
like what the [ __ ] pump is 22 I'm like
yeah yeah I'm still a kid you're still a
kid bro yeah it's pretty wild